hey this is pressure Locker this problem
involves three cards one card is blue on
both sides another card is red on both
sides and the last is red on one side
and blue on the other I place the three
cards in a bag and I randomly grab one
of the cards without looking at the
colors on the card I place the card on
the table I then let go and I see that
the face-up side the side that's showing
is blue the question is what's the
probability the facedown side the other
side of the card is also blue give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution this
is a counterintuitive probability
problem the answer is not one-half the
reason is there are three equally likely
ways to pick a card and aside to show a
blue side one of the ways you can show a
blue side is if you pick the red blue
card and you show the blue side another
case is if you pick the blue blue card
and you show one of its sides and a
final way is if you pick the blue blue
card and you show its other side if you
would pick the red blue card then the
other side of the card would be red but
in the other two cases the other side
would be blue therefore in two out of
the three cases the other side of the
card is actually blue and therefore the
probability the other side is blue is
2/3 intuitively this is because if you
picked a card and you saw that one of
its sides which was picked at random is
blue it's actually more likely that you
pick the blue blue card it's two times
more likely you picked a blue blue card
then you pick the red blue card now to
show why this is the case let's do a
simulation we'll get started by writing
out the cards in the problem one card is
blue on both sides another card is red
on both sides and the final card is red
on one side
and blue on the other side those three
cards are put into a bag and I pick a
random card I then place that card on
the table and I show a random side of
that card in this simulation in order to
do that we're going to want to know the
probability of the random card we pick
has a blue side from the random side
which is showing we care about only the
cases in which the side showing is blue
and then we care about if it's blue we
want to know is the other side also blue
so we want to calculate the probability
that the other side is blue given that
we know that one of the sides showing is
blue so we want to keep track of the
number of trials in which one of the
sides is blue and then we want to keep
track of the number of trials in which
the other side is blue so to get started
with the simulation we want to pick a
random card from the three cards there
are many different ways to do this but
I'll just show you one way I'll first
associate a random number between 0 & 1
to each of the cards as I do each trial
these random numbers are going to change
the highest random number can be thought
of as the first card in the deck the
next highest as the next card in the
deck and the lowest as the lowest card
in the deck to pick a random card I'm
going to start out by thinking about
taking these three cards and then I'm
going to pick the rank of this random
number relative to the other random
numbers so it's basically like I'm
shuffling the cards in a deck and then
I'm picking one of the cards at random
as I'm going to use this formula to copy
it down I'm just going to put some
absolute references on the cards so each
time I do a trial we're going to be
picking a different random card now I
need to pick a random side of that card
so it'll help to actually calculate the
probability that one of the sides of the
cards is blue so if the card is equal to
blue blue then clearly the
probability of a blue side is equal to 1
if the card is equal to red blue then
the probability is 50% because there's a
50% chance of red or blue and if it's
not blue blue or it's not red red then
we must be sorry if it's not blue blue
or red blue then we must be in the red
red case so then there will be a 0%
chance of having blue side so we can
pick a random side of the card base on
this probability that we have a blue
side so if a random number I generate is
less than this probability I'm going to
say the card is blue and otherwise the
card is red so each time I do trial this
is going to give me a random side of
this random card that I picked so now
let's get to the part about the side
showing is blue and then considering if
the other side is blue so we only care
about cases in which this is equal to
blue in that case I'm going to have an
indicator variable of an indicator of 1
and otherwise I'm going to put 0 and
finally the other side will be blue only
if the random card we selected is equal
to blue blue so let me copy these
formulas down and we'll have a few
trials so I'll explain how this works so
let's consider the first trial here
we've selected the red blue card there's
a 50% chance we show red and 50% chance
we show blue it happened in this trial
that we showed a blue side so the side
showing was blue we're going to count
this trial but the other side is not
blue in the next trial
we picked a red red card which we're
just going to exclude because we didn't
even show this one of the sides is blue
this would never have happened this
happened in the next trial in the next
trial after that the 4th trial we picked
a blue blue card so we're going to show
a blue side and the other side is going
to be blue in this trial we picked a red
blue card but the side showing was red
so this does not actually correspond to
the problem that we
showed one of the sides showing was blue
so we're not even going to count this
trial at all we're only going to count
trials in which we see one of the blue
sides is showing and then consider
whether the other side is blue so let's
go ahead and copy this down about 10000
times and count the number of times in
which we have a side showing which is
blue and we'll count the number of times
in which the other side is also blue
so I'll simulate this by copied down
this formula now the spreadsheet will
calculate all of these variables so
let's count the number of times in which
one of the sides is blue that'll be
column G so this is 5000 it's about 50%
of the trials 5,000 out of 10,000 that's
actually what we expect and now we want
to know the number of times that the
other side is blue so that'll be column
H so now we want to calculate the ratio
that the other side is blue to seeing
that one of the sides is blue and as you
can see this is very close to our
theoretical probability calculation of
2/3 so it is true that if you pick a
random card you show one of the sides at
random you see that it's blue the
probability that the other side is blue
will be 2/3 thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker if you liked the video please
check out my books there are links in
the video description